according to your IMDB it says that the
role for Scutt Farkus came down between
you and another red-haired boy at that
time yeah and let's just say that the
other actor got the role and you didn't
okay okay do you think things would have
taken off because you know how they say
that one thing usually kind of sets
people in motion and they would always
see maybe scut all the time do you think
that that changed everything that one
instance of you I know you've had
several callbacks I guess for the role
mm-hmm change things for you in terms of
if you didn't get it but you still came
to LA maybe you came in your 20s I know
medically to try to take your shot that
you would be here grinding it out the
way slightly talented people are as well
I think if I didn't get a Christmas
story then definitely my life story
would be different because when
Christmas Story came out it wasn't a
success nobody liked it it was in the
theaters for two weeks and then it was
replaced by Rambo - I think it then came
out a following year nobody cared
Leonard Maltin retracted a review that
he had posted apparently he had liked it
the first year but then said this is a
great movie but really no one cared it
wasn't really until the twentieth
anniversary where its tipping point
became sort of galvanized Americana to
be something that they all said yes this
is our Christmas movie and I think it
was at that point forward where people
just appreciated that I've been in it it
was wasn't that cool you know that guy
was skip Farkas yeah no no shut that guy
yeah so I think yeah he's still I think
and it was it became became kind of a
fanboy thing honestly I hate I did a TV
show for Joss Whedon dollhouse and I
need an epitaph on an epitaph - and his
brother Jett Whedon and is Marisa his
wife cast it
and jet was saying later he he was just
so excited to work with Scot Farkas and
I think what was odd about it is that
you know all the other kids Peter
Billingsley is a producer does Ironman
and works with Vince Vaughn so he's got
a huge production company and what a
different way from an earlier age and I
did and so he doesn't really have the
same experience he doesn't really care
to talk about it it's not something that
he puts a smile on his face I have had
sort of the opposite experience which
was I've been working after all my life
and so for people to come up and go oh
my gosh we want you every year and it's
great and my little kid Billy I got him
Red Ryder BB on he's like yeah it's like
yeah so yeah nice to meet you son and
then the grandfather was like yours like
that when I was your boy you know in all
this it for me is the best Christmas
experience there is and I think I would
miss that most of all I think how it
affected my career is it made people
realize my longevity and know that I'm
sort of a marathoner and not a sprinter
you